An absolute rollercoaster.
I got to learn about myself.
I got to learn how to open up,
I got to learn how to put myself out there.
Once in a lifetime.
Once in a lifetime, yeah.
Kinda like being at summer camp.
Where you just bond with people and suddenly,
you’re telling them your deepest, darkest secrets.
I was like: ‘’Look, I’m gonna go and
have as muchfun as I possibly can
while it lasts.’’
And then ten episodes later,
I’m in the final with my girlfriend.
It was an absolute blast,
I met some ofthe funniest, hottest, cool people.
Everyone was super open-minded.
Amazing, I felt like I learnt a
lot.
Like, Lana showed me so much.
It was such an enjoyable experience
and I thinkit’s something that everyone should try at leastonce,
if they have the opportunity.
Although it was very hard to share a room
with twelve people that I just had met.
Good morning beautiful people!
I can say that’s one of my favorite memories now.
I miss so much hearing all the morning jokes,
staring at their morning-just-woke-up faces,
gossiping with the girls about all
the drama going on in the house.
My favorite memory probably has to be when
Lana popped out of that sunroof,
and it wasrevealed that we were on Too Hot To Handle.
I can truly say that I had absolutely no idea.
My most impactful memories and parts for
me, was when we had that all boys workshop.
I’ve always, like, used the yoni for myself,
without taking, like,
the yoni’s owner into consideration.
We really shared our vulnerabilities
through our day conversations and, yeah,
justunderstanding where all the boys kinda come from
while we were in this retreat together.
Thatwas something that I really enjoyed because
we all kind of connected on our vulnerabilities.
Seeing Jawa win was great, for not only me,
but everybody else and seeing everybody
come together, no matter who won,
that was what makes us a family.
The hardest part of the experience for me
was choosing between Dom, Kayla and Jawa.
I wish I had the chance to get
in everyone’s bed but I can’t.
Walking to the room and seeing Brittan in the bedwith James.
Got a new sleeping partner have I?
Didn’t deal with that very well.
The world was going to get
to look in with a finetooth comb
at my emotions and how I was feeling ina relationship that,
you know, I put my all into.
That was a hard experience for me.
I usually say communication ismy strong suit.
But man, having to
really expose yourself and talk about
everything, from your heart and your feelingsand your emotions
to people you that have never metin your entire life...
Man, it’s definitely tough.
I’m a lot more open to new relationships,new beginnings.
Having more respect andlove and care for myself, and mybody, so...
Lana, you did your thing!
I think I turned the naughty Nigel
switch back on, Lana. I’m so sorry!
I’ve been trying to focus that abundance
of feelings into different outlets,
so I’ve been writing poetry and fantasy
short stories.
I’m going to ballet again.
Since filming, I’ve been a busy boy.
I’m thefounder of a tech company,
I was flying allaround to see all my castmates that I love.
Since filming, I've been working really, really hard
on building up mylifestyle content for my social media,
and also I was nominated to the People’s Choice
Awards as Best Latin influencer,
and I won!
Brittan and I took a little bit of a break
when we got back from Too Hot To Handle.
We both had this new perspective fromLana,
and we both just didn’t reallyknow where we stood with each other.
We both moved to Los Angeles,
started seeing each other a lot more.
I guess you can say James and I are in
the dating phase, the dating process.
Man, it feels great to say that.
Undefined, ladies don’t kiss and tell.
I am single and ready to mingle though.
I am not single.
I’m gonna probably stay single
for a little bit longer.
So, I’m currently single.
Very complicated.
In a relationship.
At first, Seb and Iwere dating for a few months.
I travelledto Scotland.
It was a lot, all at once.
The long distance got really difficult for
us both, which was, it was always a fear.
The one thing that scares me most: the person I’m
falling for lives on the other side of the world.
We ended up ending things mutually
but we did not stop communication.
I’m still very much in love with her.
I think we’ve got enough memories
to continue something together.
So hopefully soon we’ll give things another try.
Guys, I’m single and I’m so not ready to mingle.
Following the retreat I moved to London,
and we were together nonstop.
I got my heart broken because I fell in love.
I got to live together with
Nick and eventually things didn’t work out.
I need myself and I need
my foundations established.
I’m focusing on me, doing what I
want to do, exploring my curiosities.
I’m gonna spend my twenties just loving, and
growing and just evolving as a young woman.